y
hay dos cosas que me apasionan
enormemente
y disfruto mucho en la vida uno de ellos
es la creatividad y luego otra vez el
liderazgo a lo largo de todo este tiempo
he podido trabajar con muchos equipos de
trabajo con mucha gente en áreas
ejecutivas y también con gente que forme
equipos creativos y dentro de ellos he
encontrado algo que se va propagando
cada vez dentro de nosotros como un
vídeo y es que cada vez al parecer
estamos más y más cansadas
anteriormente nosotros clasificamos la
gente por pájaros madrugadores o búhos
nocturnos decíamos que según teníamos
nosotros nuestra hora a esa de esa
manera nosotros funcionamos mejor a
quienes se dicen que son más activos en
la noche que por eso son los bonos
nocturnos a esa hora que se amortizan
pero la verdad es que he podido concluir
de que hoy en día nosotros que estamos
cansados prácticamente a todas horas y
no veas en la eternidad
[Música]
también hemos podido ver de un estudio
que no sé
estaba la fundación latinoamericana
educarte que los jóvenes con edades
entre 17 y 20 años alrededor de
latinoamérica duermen un promedio de 6
horas al día es decir no estamos
nosotros recuperando nuestro sueño o
nuestro descanso no no quisieron incluir
los fines de semana porque ya me imagino
pero
nosotros podemos culpar a muchas cosas
desde él porque nosotros no le damos
importancia al descanso podemos decir
que es netflix podemos decir que es
whatsapp podemos decir las redes
sociales pero la verdad es una sola y es
que cada vez estamos más y más cansados
tan es así que nosotros hemos hecho del
café algo como un elixir de la vida
prácticamente nosotros
lo hemos puesto verdad como un brebaje
que nos devuelve a nosotros
[Música]
nuestro día
hace poco un reportaje de diario la
prensa mostraba que en promedio los
hondureños consumimos alrededor de 7
libras de café al año es decir más de
700 tazas de café por persona es algo
sorprendente como nosotros hemos
incrementado y fuera de esto de lo que
son bebidas energizantes y todo lo demás
para revitalizarlos
también es importante encontrar que en
un libro del doctor través de read que
se llama inteligencia emocional 2.0 él
indica que cuando nosotros no tenemos el
descanso adecuado
nuestras decisiones son peores nuestro
funcionamiento es peor nos volvemos más
irritables andamos de mal humor y
prácticamente erosiona mos nuestras
relaciones tratamos mal a la gente con
que trabajamos pero sobre todo
constantemente bajamos nuestro
rendimiento y nuestro desempeño que
podemos decir nosotros al respecto
como una persona curiosa acerca del
comportamiento humano y de todo lo que
es los hábitos de consumo en el año 2016
comenzamos a incluir un par de preguntas
en algunos estudios de mercado que
hacíamos para nuestros clientes por lo
general los estudios que hacíamos
referente a preferencias de marca pero
siempre incluyamos dos preguntas que
tuvieran que ver con el management del
tiempo y como ellos hacían uso de su
descanso los hallazgos que tuvimos ahí
fueron bastante relevantes bastante
importante y dentro de ellos que les
puedo compartir de que la mayoría de las
personas que salieron en este estudio
mostraban
5 cosas que realmente los agotados creo
que todos podemos hablar acerca de este
tipo de cosas o sentirnos identificados
con ellos porque déjenme decirles en
primer lugar la mayoría de las personas
decían que la mayor causa de su
agotamiento número uno era por las malas
horas de sueño y dentro de la causa
principal dentro de malas horas de sueño
estaba el uso de videojuegos no sé que
tenga que ver el ratón
la segunda causa que encontrábamos
porque tenían el gran agotamiento es por
la mala alimentación la mala
alimentación ciertamente conlleva a que
nosotros no podamos tener un descanso
reparador hay alimentos que nos energiza
y hay alimentos que también nos quitan
energía
la tercera causa es cuando hay un mal
ambiente laboral la mayoría de las
personas coincidían en que al tener un
mal ambiente de trabajo o sentirse mal
en el trabajo esto les afectaba
directamente en su descanso en su sueño
o en sentirse energizado para la
actividad del día siguiente lo mismo el
cuarto punto que encontramos es que
cuando llevan trabajo a la casa también
eso les afectaba en el descanso o en el
sueño que tenía lo noto lógico porque me
parece que es muy difícil desconectarse
de las actividades laborales para
después ir automáticamente a dormir y la
quinta causa bueno es algo que no
entendemos los sampedranos decían que la
quinta causa de no tener un sueño
reparador el calor
entonces a sí mismo como nosotros vimos
estos aspectos les consultábamos cuales
eran las otras cinco cosas que realmente
a ellos los energiza van que cosas a
ellos realmente los hacía sentir mucho
mejor
tener un listado de estos creíamos
nosotros a la mano podía ser muy útil
para que ellos detectaron que
necesitaban hacer antes de que el
agotamiento extremo llegar y dentro de
las muchas razones nosotros
acercamos estas cinco cosas que nos
energiza van las agrupamos y descubrimos
que un 80 por ciento de las personas que
estaban ahí cuando sentían el
agotamiento o se sentían cansados decían
que lo número 1 el 80 por ciento decía
que lo primero que más nos energiza va a
ellos es tener amigos con quienes
conversar
parece que para nosotros es muy
importante de tragarnos analizar las
cosas que nos suceden en nuestro día a
día ahí es donde podemos ver la
importancia de las relaciones
el otro 65% decía que los energiza va
mucho salir de su hábitat algo que nos
parece entendible muchas veces cuando
nosotros estamos encerrados en un mismo
lugar necesitamos un aire fresco para
poder liberar toxinas ver cosas
diferentes
el tercer aspecto que
sentían que los energiza va también eran
en hacer cosas diferentes e intentar
cosas nuevas el tener propósitos retos
nosotros debemos de entender que
nosotros no podemos vivir una vida
energizada si no tenemos metas o logros
por conquistar esto es algo que nos da
en curso algo que nos lleva que enciende
nuestro corazón para hacer cosas nuevas
el cuarto aspecto que lo llevaba a eso
es precisamente
el disfrutar de la música la música al
parecer también fue un factor común que
encontramos en todos ellos como un
energizante
también déjenme decirles que me di mi
tarea propia en estar cuáles eran esas
cinco cosas que me energiza van para
tenerlas a la mano para poder
contar con ellas y puedo compartirles
que el número uno lo que me energiza
primero que nada es la música cuando uno
tiene su día extenuante creo yo de que
pone su música y uno siente que se
recupere el año lo segundo que le puedo
decir que me energiza mucho es correr
siento que el ejercicio el hecho de que
el corazón esté a punto de salirse a uno
lo energiza cuando uno termina de hacer
su jornada de ejercicio uno siente que
recupera recuperado algo de uno mismo y
la mente por alguna razón el oxígeno y
todo sería claro lo tercero que
mediatiza mucho también es tener
conversaciones profunda y esto implica
que para tener conversaciones profundas
nosotros debemos de saber con quién
tenerlas hay gente preseleccionada que
yo sé que puedo dar una llamada y decir
sabes que podemos tomarnos un café
podemos sentarnos a platicar
y eso honestamente nos ayuda bastante a
energizar nos el quinto punto de lo que
a mí me energiza también es intentar
cosas nuevas
proponerme el hacer cosas nuevas
te quiero decir con esto cuál es la idea
que quiero dejarles
si nosotros tenemos conciencia
de que el agotamiento es algo que cada
vez es más crónico en nosotros y tenemos
a la mano o hacemos de antemano han
actualizado a las cinco cosas semanas de
ejercicios que ejercitan lo que más nos
energiza
nosotros podemos antes de que lleguemos
a un agotamiento extremo poder
realizarlos y recargar algo tan sencillo
como eso pero mucha gente que le
pregunto dio constante hace un mes un
listado de las cinco cosas que se
energiza realmente no lo tienen hecho a
mano yo los invito a que ésta sea una
idea práctica si ustedes pueden
complementar para poderla realizar
recordemos que cuidar mente y cuerpo
debe de ser parte del criterio que todos
queremos
[Aplausos]